[Music]
good morning John it's Wednesday no yes
yes Wednesday March 14th if it looks
like I'm cold and tired it's because I'm
gold and tired oh I got up early this
morning so I could prepare for a phone
call I have two very important meetings
today I had one very important meeting
yesterday this is the most very
important meetings I've ever had in a
two day period my very important meeting
today starts in three minutes and it is
with Yahoo they're uh like a search
engine and they have email and some news
er I don't know I can't tell you what
they're calling about because it is
confidential it's officially time for me
to call in about Yahoo number and get
started at my meeting I have finished
the Yahoo call so I started at the yahoo
called by mentioning that I had done
some research on the people who I was
having a call with and I didn't say oh I
looked you up on the internet to the
people at Yahoo no I said I googled you
owe people a yahoo don't Google people
at Yahoo would rather you not Google
people at Yahoo Yahoo and I don't Yahoo
other than that the meeting went very
well John I've been thinking about
nerdfighters and I've been thinking that
there should be a way to become a
nerdfighter possibly a series of tasks I
think the first one of these tasks is to
figure out what kind of nerdfighter you
are the second task would be to write a
lyric of the nerdfighter song from the
perspective of that nerdfighter
character I think I might be a Magic the
Gathering nerd even know what Magic the
Gathering is when I was in high school
was definitely one of the nerdiest
things you could do and I was extra
nerdy about it because I was really bad
but I kept playing the idea is that you
have cards and they're kind of
collectible they rank from really common
cards to really rare cards but there are
rules about the cards like you can't
play a certain card unless you have
other cards out and then you can attack
using your cards you can
the other person's cards in your cards
have ratings for defense and attack
power it's really very complicated when
I say complicated
I mean nerdy okay I think I figured out
my nerdfighter song my collectible card
games are underrated
complicated in sophisticated if you
think that my powers could be defeated
just mashup and Dragon and get burning
needed
nerdfighter a cards have power I'm a
wizard of the coast and I rarely shower
[Music]
haha nerdfighters I'll see you tomorrow
do you want to be a nerdfighter to click
on the sidebar brotherhood to comm which
has nerdfighters and tell us what kind
of nerdfighter you are and put in your
nerdfighter lyrics